c'est vrai qu'on en a fait du chemin on
a fait ça fait cinquante et un jour je
vous le dis de ce soir chez ba ba oui et
c'est vrai que le premier jour on avait
un canapé s'est installé dans une petite
pièce on va revenir sur la naissance de
ce soir chez ba ba est ce que l'on nous
annonce et le confinement le lendemain
j'ai dit à ses huit je veux faire
l'émission de chez moi on vous a préparé
un petit récap regardez bien d'où on
vient et je peux vous dire comme disait
corneille parce qu'on vient de loin
regarde depuis le début du confinement
cyril a décidé de réagir et de faire
comme une grande partie des français qui
le peuvent travailler depuis la maison
c'est donc depuis son canapé que depuis
le 17 mars dernier il a lancé le tout
premier numéro de ce soir shebab à une
émission au départ un peu moins
dynamique que tpm peut s'allumer beauté
très vite cyril reprend ses marques et
prend conscience de la gravité de la
situation en france en abordant des
sujets importants riz à une question sur
le cac a qui arrivent dans un instant là
bien entendu il faut dire que baba a
réponse à tout je connais les sentiments
humains je connais la vie je connais les
gens grâce à une technologie de pointe
et pas mal d'huile de coude
il parvient réaliser des duplex digne
d'un jt de 20 heures ça va les frérots
je vois pas les frérots whaou vous
entends les pré roll on voit pas ahola
mon frérot comment ça va très vite il
retrouve également son franc parler en
ce moment il n'y a pas de public on ne
lui demande pas une pub tf1 qu'est-ce
qui vient nous faire chier non mais
franchement et gilles verdez toujours
plus à l'aise avec son corps d'athlète
se sont très vite comme à la maison
qu'il est con mais non mais une émission
qui on se rassure ne déroge pas à la
longue tradition instaurée par tpm fait
du fameux bug technique
ah oui
voilà donc dorian a posé une question
mais tu l'as pas vu en fait n'en a pas
vu non alors luria dataplus eshop un
programme naturel fait maison qui va
nous manquer on kiffe d'être avec vous
alors je voudrais remercier aussi très
chaleureusement
jimmy mohamed dit mohamed qualité
exceptionnelle qui est vraiment un ami
que j'aime énormément et qui a été
fabuleux voilà pour répondre à toutes
vos questions et il a pris du temps
parce qu'il travaillait également
donc merci a dit me merci à jean michel
cohen aussi inquiets du souvent des
grands tous les médecins aussi qui sont
venus qui nous ont aidés voilà et qui
ont intervenu qui sont intervenus
professeur a donné à tous tout nécessité
mais voilà vous les connaissez voilà et
tous ceux qui nous ont aidés et on a eu
des vraies vrai coup de coeur sur des
personnes qui nous ont aidés à faire
cette émission et c'est vrai bravo et
merci à 18 mois m on va revoir la toute
première image de l'émission c'était le
17 mars à 17h47 c'était un mardi
regardez c'est une dar k il n'y a même
pas de lumière on dirait c'est vraiment
on a l'impression d'être sur france 2
quand ils font des prize regarde saluer
beauté et bat ça et voilà on en direct
on est bien avec mesa villalier gilles
verdez ladjimi mohamed pouvez nous poser
toutes vos questions les chéris je vous
appellerai d'ici alors il faut vous
sachiez que je fais tout on en direct la
sur ces 8 c'est historique 1 franchement
voilà donc je fais tous là je réalise
d'ici regard des géomètres un petit peu
l'envoyer sur gilles verdez et jimmy
mohamed lavoyer voilà la jv la voilà et
voilà voilà voilà voilà oui ça va dit
bonjour bonjour voila voila regard des
géomètres un gros plan sur jvc valade
gill derrière ça va je suis content
d'arriver
voilà c'est pas mal ça et je reviens sur
moi je reviens sur moi ça va mais chéri
alors bon on est tous confinés
on va pas se mentir donc voilà on à la
maison il ne faut pas sortir restez chez
vous les chéris j'ai mis des lunettes de
soleil sur pourquoi c'est la question la
dapa unis et malik bentalha qui
m'envoyait c'est m il m'a dit juste
voilà est-ce que je peux de bonnes
occasions pourquoi tally des lunettes de
soleil dans l'émission fait peur mais
franchement pourquoi ouailles os ou de
vente
mon bras je me suis échauffé peut se
gagner ma vie c'est quoi confinement à
les lunettes de soleil il ya jean pascal
qui nous dit il à jean pascal lacoste
qui nous dit qu'il est tellement heureux
d'être dans notre team l'année prochaine
et la rentrée ça va être dingue je te le
confirme mon jean pascal que j'aime
énormément qu'il ya un vrai gars bien
que je connais depuis des années
vous allez voir chez vous dire tout ce
qu'ils m'ont dit on rejoint qui vont
faire des chroniques en entrée/sortie
tout ça il ya des beaux gosses il ya des
bugs les chiens on va voir un petit peu
d'évolution du décor de halo baba parce
que c'est vrai qu'il ya beaucoup de gens
qui en parlent alors au départ c'était
la bibliothèque éclatement c'était
vraiment la tristesse regarder la
bibliothèque cyril hanouna
voilà on a vécu des moments sombres on a
envie de dire un voilà des de l'histoire
des deux corps dans la télévision
française
ensuite on a changé on a fait faute au
salon quand j'étais en mode salon
regarder d'où on vient regardez voilà
voilà voilà voilà voilà
c'était ça ensuite on a débloqué du
budget j'ai une télé dans le salon
regardez voilà ensuite on est passé par
ça là on était sur fun tv 2002 et là
c'est pas une lubie 2002 et la regarder
alors on a fait le max regardez on est
pas mal
voilà regardez maintenant aujourd'hui
voilà dernières photos là on est plus
voilà on est bien mais on est limite
chez darty voilà on sait pas trop voilà
on est chez régal y voilà on est chéri
gagne mais on a fait le max et bravo à
mon philippe belaïch voilà là on est un
petit peu voilà on a un petit blanc on
dirait qu'on vend des allogènes
on dirait quand on est dans un magasin
de luminaires
voilà mais on aime bien quand même voilà
en tout cas il ya une ampoule ses sens
il ya monde alex israël voilà qui est lé
directeur des divertissements et des
magazines de la chaîne qui me mais
c'était où cette émission merci de nous
avoir fait kiffer comme ça on va c'est
qu'on va s'éclater sur à prendre ou à
laisser voilà merci monde alex qui est
toujours là et toujours avec nous et
merci d'ailleurs à toutes les équipes je
leur dit c'est 8 qui ont fait un travail
est fait est exceptionnel
alors ensuite un moment qui ont été
chauffées sais pas si vous vous rappelez
j'avais fait une chronique pendant ce
confinement ketting chronique où je
faisais la cuisine
que les téléspectateurs s'en souvient on
a vu mes talents de cuisinier bien
entendu alors bon chez moi
la cuisine ça a duré cinq jours après
j'ai stoppé
voilà je vous le dis regardez j'ai quand
même quitté préparé des petits des
petites recettes avec vous regarde
confiné depuis chez lui très vite cyril
a décidé de faire profiter de toute la
france de ses talents de cuistot des
talents qui ont inspiré les plus grands
qui copient régulièrement les astuces du
chef baba un chef qui nous a concocté
des délices gustatif grâce à son four
haute technologie larmont la vie life
pour allumer et après à lui et à aa
s'il préfère la cuisine à l'ancienne
c'est que cyril bab al honi de son vrai
nom est fils d'un pizzaïolo une
tradition familiale qui lui est cher et
qu'il a su mettre à l'honneur dans les
missions réelles et repeint
mais ne croyez pas que baba ne sais
cuisiner que les pizzas
ce chef quatre fois étoilé au pneu
michelin a régalé les téléspectateurs
avec son plat signature la tourte aux
champignons
faites chauffer l'huile d'olive dans une
poêle et faites y revenir les
champignons ait aulaye du sel et du
poivre à feu moyen durant dix minutes ça
aussi
j'ai demandé à quelqu'un d' homme le
faire un plat copieux qui pour ceux qui
ont eu la chance de le goûter
reste aussi longtemps en tête que sur
l'estomac et ouais et merci aux
téléspectateurs qui m'ont soutenu
merci à la vie de barbe est aussi voilà
ce journaliste qui nous dit merci on
s'est régalé pendant toute cette période
louis jean michel je sais bien je sais
bien nous arriver à tous le dos et vous
d'évaluer mais moi j'ai des copines qui
ont étudié vos recettes qui sont
reproduits il se régale depuis c'est
fantastique c'est à dire ça oui merci
voilà on espère on espère qu'elles
seront pas empoisonner vous me dites pas
sinon voilà
ne vous inquiétez pas